[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه
السودان يعلن عن الاتفاق مع اسرائيل على
المضيق قدما في تطبيع العلاقات بين
البلدين
نتنياهو في باريس للقاء ماكرون ايران
وتدخلاتها باوكرانيا على راس جدول العمل
الشراع في داخل النظام الايراني موشي جديد
بس حاليا في مق
ابله عربيه
يكشف عن صراعات داخل النظام الايراني
وفي القضايا السياسيه التي شغلت مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعيات تتابعنا ايضا
موقع تشاد جي بي تي الاسرع نموا في
التاريخ من حيث عدد المستخدمين وجوجل تخشى
من المنافسه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم البدايه من السودان حيث اعلنت
وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه لاتفاق مع
اسرائيل على المضي قدما في تطبيع العلاقات
بين البلدين وقال بيان للوزاره ان وزير
الخارجيه علي الصادق التقى نظيره
الاسرائيلي اليكوهن حيث تم الاتفاق على
تطوير علاقات البلدين في مجالات الزراعه
والطاقه والصحه والمياه والتعليم واضافت
الخارجيه السودانيه انه تم حذف اسرائيل
على العمل على تحقيق الاستقرار والسلام
للشعب الفلسطيني
وينضم الينا عبر الهاتف من القدس مراسل
العربيه زياد حلبي اهلا بك زياد يعني ليست
المره الاولى التي يزور فيها ايلي كوهن
الخرطوم قبلها كان يحمل حقيبه
الاستخبارات بحكومه سابقه ما تفاصيل هذه
الزياره
بان الزياره لافته
وطبعا احيطت بالسريه لاسباب امنيه عاده في
اسرائيل يقدرون بان الامور ذاهبه
في اتفاق مع السودان على تطبيع العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بشكل كامل للتذكير السودان
وقع على اتفاقات ابراهيم ولكنه لم يوقع
بعدها وقع على الجوانب الاقتصاديه ولكنه
لم يوقع بعدها على
التبادل عمليا التفاهمات مع اسرائيل
مباشره وقع لوزير الخزانه الامريكيه في
حينه وبالتالي الان يجري العمل على اتمام
هذا الموضوع لكن
التقديرات يعني لا تتوقع ان يتم ذلك قبل
ان تشكل الحكومه مدنيه في السودان زياد
يعني هناك مؤتمر صحفي مرتقب بعد قليل
لوزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي كوهان ما
المتوقع ان يعلنه خلاله
طبعا سيطفي هاله من التاريخيه على هذه
الزياره وعلى قضيه الاتفاق مع السودان
لانه بالنسبه لاسرائيل هذه ليست اتفاقيه
سلام مع دوله عربيه عاديه هذه مع دوله كان
كان في بينها وبين اسرائيل عزاء مباشره
للتذكير فقط عام 2009 اسرائيل شلت غارات
على السودان عمليا قالت حينها انها دمرت
مخازن اسلحه تابعه لحماس كانت السودان
تخزن فيها الاسلحه في العام 2012 ايضا
اسرائيل شنت غارات على مصانع قالت انها
مصانع ايرانيه على الاراضي
السودانيه بهذا المعنى كان هناك اصطدام
مباشر عسكري مع السودان يضاف طبعا الى ذلك
كله رمزيه الخرطوم في تاريخ الصراع العربي
الثلاثه المشهوره التي كانت الخرطوم لا
للمفاوضات لا للاعتراف
للسلام مع اسرائيل وبالتالي بالنسبه
لاسرائيل قد يكون هذا امرا مهما جدا
بالذات ان يكون هناك علاقات دبلوماسيه
كامله مع السودان زد على ذلك بانها بان
اسرائيل
تضعوا عينها تماما على القاره السمراء
لجهه العلاقات الدبلوماسيه راينا اليوم
فقط شاهد تتته السفاره قرب تل ابيب
عمليا الرئيس تشادي كان في اسرائيل زياد
ان يكون اتفاق التطبيع مع السودان بين
السودان واسرائيل على بعد خطوات قليله ما
الذي سيشكله من فرق بالداخل الاسرائيلي
بالنسبه لنتنياهو وهذه الحكومه التي تتعرض
لضغوطات كبيره
هذا صحيح جدا بالنسبه لنتنياهو لديه انجاز
في جعبته وهو اتفاقات
ابراهيم مع الامارات والبحرين
والسودان عمليا وبالتالي بالنسبه له هذا
امر مهم جدا
للحكومه لان لديه النظريه العكسيه لعمليه
السلام كما يمكن ان نسميها عمليا مبادره
السلام العربيه كانت نصت على ان تطبيع
العلاقات مع الدول العربيه كافه
والاسلاميه يتم فقط بعد انهاء الصراع مع
الفلسطينيين نتنياهو يقول ان العكس يجب ان
يحدث وهو يعمل في هذا الاتجاه منذ سنوات
بالتالي سيجير ذلك انجازا له بالنسبه له
بدون مشاكل في مواجهه ايضا الهزه القويه
التي تضرب الحكومه هذه الايام في الداخل
الاسرائيلي يعني لا يضيره اتفاق سلام الان
يعلن عنه في الفتره المقبله كما قلت
التوقعات بعد اشهر يعني لم يكون
هذا الامر نعم شكرا جزيلا لك زياد حلبي
مراسل العربيه من القدس على هذه المعلومات
وسنترقب وسننتظر المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي الذي تحدثنا عنه
للتعليق على هذه الزياره الى الخرطوم شكرا
الى العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس يصل رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو للقاء
الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل المكروم وعلى
قائمه البحث التوترات المتناميه بشان
ايران السفاره الاسرائيليه في باريس قالت
ان نتنياهو سيبحث مع ماكرون الجهود
الدوليه لوقف البرنامج النووي الايراني
بالاضافه الى بحث توترات في المنطقه ويسعى
الطرف الاسرائيلي خصوصا الى تركيز هذه
الزياره على موضوع ايران املا في ان يدفع
طلوع طهران المتنامي في الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا من خلال تزويد روسيا بعتاد
الدول الغربيه الى تشديد الضغوط على ايران
في حين ان المحادثات بشان الملف النووي
الايراني متوقفه ترى باريس انه ينبغي
اعتماد سياسه حازمه جدا حيال ايران ومنذ
اشهر عده باتت ايران طرفا يزداد اهميه في
النزاع الاوكراني من خلال توفير مسير
كثيره تستخدمها موسكو لضرب المنشات
الاوكرانيه وامام هذا الانخراط المتزايد
لايران في الحرب الاوكرانيه اعلن نتنياهو
انه بات مستعدا للتفكير في تزويد اوكرانيا
باسلحه فيما يبدو انه تغيير كبير في موقف
اسرائيل علما انه اكد ايضا استعداده للاعب
دوري الوسيط في هذا النزاع
تدفق الاسلحه الغربيه الى اوكرانيا لا
يزال مستمرا اذا بل ان الامر بلغ درجه
التنويع في العتاد بارسال اسلحه اكثر
تطورا اخر الاسلحه التي ستصل الى اوكرانيا
انظمه رادار للدفاع الجوي المزود سيكون
فرنسا التي قررت اذا ارسال انظمه رادار
لتتبع تهديدات الصواريخ والمسيارات
الروسيه هذا ما كشف عنه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني
الذي وصف ارسال هذه الرادارات بمثابه
الكرز على الكعكه على حد تعبيره كما اكد
وزير الدفاع الفرنسي سيباستيانو ارسال
فرنسا للرادارات الحربيه وذلك بهدف انقاذ
ارواح الاوكرانيين على حد وصفه انظمه
الرادارات الفرنسيه التي سيتم ارسالها
لاوكرانيا الهدف منها حسب وزاره الدفاع
الفرنسيه حمايه المناطق الاهله بالسكان
وتسمى هذه الرادارات نظام جراوند ماستر
200 وهي رادارات متوسطه المدى تصنعها شركه
الفرنسيه
جي ام 200 هو رادار عباره عن جهاز استشعار
للدفاع الجوي قادر على تغطيه دائره قطرها
250 كيلومتر ويمكن تشغيل هذا الرادار عن
بعد كما انه يعمل بالذكاء الاصطناعي قادر
ايضا على استشعار الاصوات اللاسلكيه
تستطيع هذه الرادارات تتبع طائرات
هليكوبتر وصواريخ الكروز وايضا قذائف
الهاون والمسيرات حتى ان كانت من وراء
التضاريس ينضم الينا من باريس مراسل
العربيه حسين قنيبر اهلا بك احسان يعني
اذا هناك زياره
لنتنياهو الى العاصمه الفرنسيه سيصل بعد
قليل ماذا في اجنده هذه الزياره والملفات
التي ستناقش
اهلا بك راويه في قصر الاليزا حيث انا
موجود يحاولون ان يستمروا في لعب دور وسطي
ازاءه عده نزاعات الملفات التي سيناقشها
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بعد دقائق من
الان عندما يصل الى هنا الى قصر الرئاسه
الفرنسيه تبدا اولا
بالصراعات في المنطقه تحديدا ما كان جرى
قبل ايام من هجمات متبادله يعني الهجمات
الاسرائيليه التي كانت ادانتها فرنسا
والتي ادت الى مقتل تسعه مدنيين فلسطينيين
في عمليه لقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه في
مخيم جنين كما ادانت فرنسا هجوم القدس
الذي ادى ايضا الى مقتل سبعه اسرائيليين
لكن ماكرون لن يضع لن يصرف شيئا من رصيده
كما يقول مصدر دبلوماسي على ملفات
بمعنى انه لن يلعب جهدا كبيرا لن يلعب
دورا كبيرا فيما يتعلق بالملف الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني لانه يعرف انه لا يستطيع ان
يغير شيئا في ظل الوضع القائم حاليا بين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين ملف ايران
سيكون في صلب المحادثات مصدر دبلوماسي قال
ان نتنياهو يسعى من خلال هذه الزياره اولا
الى شرح وجهه نظر اسرائيل التي تقول ان
الدوله العبريه تعتبر ان الخط الاحمر ليس
ان تنتج ايران قنبله نوويه بل ان تصل الى
العتبه النوويه تقنيا بمعنى ان تصبح قادره
بعد ان تجمع العناصر التقنيه ان تصبح
قادره على انتاج القنبله يسعى نتنياهو
ايضا الى دفع الغربيين نحو تحالف عسكري
سياسي ضد ايران لان اي عمليه ستقوم بها
اسرائيل ضد ايران ستؤدي الى رد ايراني
سيكون اصعب اذا كانت اسرائيل من ضمن تحالف
عسكري سياسي حتى الان با ليست متحمسه لان
تكون جزءا من تحالف سياسي عسكري ضد ايران
كما ان باريس ليست متحمسه على الاطلاق على
استعجال اسرائيل لان تنضم فرنسا للمطالبين
اوروبيا بوضع الحرس الثوري الايراني على
قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه مهما كانت
الخلافات كبيره وطهران اعتذر اعتذر عن
مقاطعتك وانتقل لهذا المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي
خلال هذا العام وسيكون
بين اسرائيل ودول بيضه بعد
الامارات ومصر والسودان
الجنر عبد الفتاح البرهان
والتقيت وزير الخارجيه ومسؤولين
اخر توقيع اتفاق السلام تخدم الطرفين
ستدعم الامن القومي لدوله اسرائيل وتقوي
الاستقرار الاقليمي وستدعم الاقتصاد
السودان هي الدوله الثالثه في ناحيه الكبر
في وهي لديها واحد فاصله ثمانيه مليون
كيلو متر دوله فيها خمسين مليون من السكان
وهي منطقه استراتيجيه شمال
القاهره شمال مصر وعلى شرطه البحر الاحمر
السودان حاربت في السابق الى جانب الدول
العربيه ضد دوله اسرائيل
وقد ارسلت في حرب الاستقلال وفي عام
واربعه
وايضا ساعدت في نقل الاسلحه لحماس السودان
كانت هناك قمه الخرطوم التي حدثت
في اسرائيل لا للمفاوضات مع اسرائيل لا
للسلام مع اسرائيل اليوم
نحن نعود هنا مع الن
عم الاعتراض باسرائيل نعم للمفاوضات مع
اسرائيل ونعم للسلام مع اسرائيل
سنه
لخمسه وسبعين
عاما لاسرائيل اريد ان اشكر الرئيس
الحكومه باليمين نتنياهو على
القياده هذه العمليه التاريخيه والولايات
المتحده برئاسه الرئيس بايدن على دعم هذا
هذه العمليه وخاصه الوزير الخارجيه
والمستشار الامن القومي سلفا ولنستثير
الولايات المتحده في خلال الزياره
تم تبادل مسوده اتفاق السلام الذي
يتوقع ان يتوقع بعد ايام الحكومه المدنيه
في انتهاء المرحله الانتقاليه في السودان
دوله اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
هذه عمليه مهمه جدا
ونائب مدير عام لشؤون افريقيا
ورئيسه هيئه الدعم
التي تعمل فيها اكثر من دوله حول العالم
بما فيها دول افريقيه
بان تقدم المساعده شكرا لك على
البكر المستشار القضائي للخارجيه
الاسرائيليه
ولممثل
مستشار الامن القومي
شكرا لك
للطاقم الذي هو ركبني في السودان
شكرا لكم جميعا
لدينا وقت قصير جدا للاسئله
ماذا سيحدث اذا لم تقم حكومه مدنيه في
السودان
وهل تحدثت مع المسؤوليه عن امكانيه طرد
طالبين اللجوء من السودان اولا
كان هناك انتخابات السودان والوضع السياسي
المركب ولكن قيل لنا بشكل واضح
من قبل البرهان رئيس الحاسوب الانتقالي
بانه في في عندما تكون
واغلبيه ائتلافيه ستكون له حكومه وهم
يسلمون مقاليد السلطه لهذه الحكومه
وهنا هذا مصلحه وعليه للسودان وهذا الامر
سيفتح امامها
امامها نافذه على دول الغربيه
وايضا اسرائيل بدون شك بان موضوع
النفاق السلام مع السودان سيكون اداه
لقضيه اعاده السودانيين الموجودين هنا الى
السودان
هذه الزياده الثانيه لك وزير الخارجيه الى
ماذا ما هو الجديد اليوم
وماذا سيكون في هذه الاتفاقيه السلام
الجديد اليوم هو انه في اللقاء الاول كان
تعارف اليوم هناك
دعم لاتفاقيه السلام في هذه السنه
ويجب ان تذكروا اننا زرت هناك قبل
هذا شهرين على اتفاقيات ابراهيم وهذه تلك
الاتفاقيات توضيح بشكل واضح بانه من الجيد
ان يكون هناك سلام بين الدول واسرائيل في
مواجهه ايران وفي تطوير الاقتصاد خمسه
مليارات دولار
والاتفاق مع السودان
الذي سيتم توقيعه خلال العام
بعد اقامه الحكم المدني الحكومه المدنيه
فياتي بعده اتفاقات اخرى
الاتفاق ليس طويلا اتفاق قصير
يرتكز الى اتفاقيات السابقه
في الاسبوع المقبل ان تتحدث مع الدكتور
بكر عن هذا الاتفاق
دوله اسرائيل ستاخذ شيء بالمقابل
وهل هناك دول اخرى على الطريق
ما يميز اتفاقيات ابراهيم واتفاق السودان
انه بين الاتفاقيات السابقه بين مصر
والاردن كان هناك تبادل الاراضي وهذا هذه
المره هي السلام في مقابل السلام فيخدم
الدولتين
ويدعم الامن الاه القومي ويحسن رفاهيه
الشعوب
ويساعد الاقتصاد ولهذا هذا الاتفاق مغاير
وهل هناك اتفاقات مع دول اخرى نحن بدون شك
نعمل على ذلك
في الخارجيه وامل
انه في خلال السنه سيكون هناك
هل هناك موعد
مع من تفضل اسرائيل العمل هل مع قائد
الحكم العسكري ام مع مدني
بالنسبه للموعد
قيل بشكل واضح
نحن في الحديث مع الرئيس السوداني بانه
يمكن التقدم في اسرع وقت ممكن يريدون ذلك
وهو جيد لهم ولنا عندما
يستكملون العمليه عندهم
يكون
بشكل سريع بعد استكمال العمليات عندهم
بالنسبه لاسرائيل لا نحدد لاي دوله من
سيقودها كل دوله لديها اعتباراتها ولهذا
نحن سنعمل مع كل من يضع من ينتخبه الشعب
السودان اريد ان اشكر القياده السودانيه
التي اختارت السنوات الاخيره الانفتاح على
الغرب دوله
حكومات سابقه فيها
دعموا
مبادره ارهابيه
وتزودوا اسلحه
وهذه هذا الحكم ياتي ويقول
وجهتي للغرب
الولايات المتحده اوروبا واسرائيل
واخذوا
قرارا قائلا برايي وابارك هذا القرار
هذا جيد لاسرائيل
شكرا شكرا
اذا نكتفي بهذا القدر من مؤتمر الصحفي
لوزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي كوهن على خلفيه
زيارته التي قام بها هذه الزياره الخاطفه
الى الخرطوم التي تمهد لاتفاق تطبيع مع
السودان طبعا وزير خارجيه اسرائيل
قال وقع الاتفاق مع السودان بشكل سريع بعد
تشكيل حكومه مدنيه واعدا بانه بنهايه هذه
السنه ستكون هناك بشرى ساره بشان السلام
وان هدف هذا الاتفاق هو السلام مقابل
السلام
وعلى عمل الحكومه الاسرائيليه على توسيع
السلام مع الدول الاخرى لمواجهه ايران
زياد حلبي ينضم الينا من القدس اهلا بك
زياد من جديد يعني
تحدث عن انه هذه الاتفاقيه يعني تمهد
وتعطي الفرصه لاقامه علاقات مع دول
افريقيه اخرى عين اسرائيل تتجه الى اين
الى اي دوله ماذا يقصد
موريتانيا من الدول التي ينظرون اليها
لتوقيع اتفاق ودول اخرى كثيره في افريقيا
عمليا بطبيعه الحال القاره الافريقي
الافريقيه يعني العلاقات مع السودان
باعتقاد اسرائيل على الاقل يمكن ان تفتح
نافذه على الدول العربيه على الدول
الافريقيه والاسلاميه تحديدا في افريقيا
لكن بدون ان بانه كما ورد في المؤتمر
الصحافي لوزير خارجيه اسرائيل وكما سبق
وقلنا بالنسبه لاسرائيل هناك يعني رمزيه
لهذا الاتفاق بالذات لانه عمليا ياتي مع
دوله مثل السودان كما قلت اسرائيل شلت
غارات على اراضي السودان في السابق
الثلاثاء الى ذلك حتى ان الوزير رايته كيف
تطرق الى هذا الموضوع تحديدا وبالتالي
ربما يعني اسرائيل تب على هذا الاتفاق
تحديدا ليس فقط في افريقيا وانما
لتحسين مكانتها وربما وضعها الدبلوماسي
الاقليمي والدولي في مواجهه ايضا التوتر
الدائم بين الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
واشنطن
شكرا جزيلا لك زياد
وينضم الينا من الخرطوم الصحفي عادل سيد
احمد اهلا بك سيد عادل يعني ما الذي
سيحصده السودان من اتفاق التطبيع مع
اسرائيل ما المامول من هذا الاتفاق
نعم انا اعتقد انه هذا الاتفاق او هذا
التطبيع بين السودان واسرائيل انا اعتقد
انه تاخر كثيرا خاصه وان دول الشر الاوسط
في معظمها طبعت مع اسرائيل بل ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه نفسها قد طبعت مع اسرائيل انا
اعتقد انه المرحله القادمه ستشهد تسريع في
هذا الملف وتطبيع بشكل اوضح وبشكل افضل
خاصه انه اذا قلت لك اشياء غير معلومه
للكثيرين انه المجتمع السوداني
ضمه جاليه يهوديه كبيره جدا كانت موجوده
منذ القرن السادس عشر وتوافدت بشكل اكبر
في القرن التاسع عشر
واصبحت يعني متاصل وموجوده داخل المجتمع
السوداني في اقاليمه وفي الولايات مختلفه
بل ان المجتمع اليهودي السودان قد ترك
بصمه كبيره جدا في مجال الصناعات الكبيره
وفي مجال الرياضه وفي مجال الثقافه وما
الى ذلك لذلك انا اعتقد انه الارض ممهده
لعمل تطبيع يخدم مصلحه السودان ومصلحه
اسرائيل حسب ما هو سائد في عالم اليوم
والذي يقوم على المصالح المشتركه السيد
عادل بما انك تحدثت عن المجتمع السوداني
الشعب السوداني الان هل هو مع اتفاق
التطبيع هذا خاصه بان القوى الشعبيه
لمناهضه التطبيع بالسودان اعتبرت ووصفت
صفقه التطبيع مع اسرائيل بانها مذله
وتنفصل تماما مع قيم الشعب السوداني يعني
هل اللاءات الثلاثه ستكون
سيضاف اليها لا رابعه حول هذا الاتفاق
يجب ان نميز بين بين العامه وبين النخب
الصحيح ان النخب وهي مرتبطه ببرامج سياسيه
وبايديولوجيات محدده لها مواقف ومرسومه
ومعروفه ومعلومه خاصه من جانب الاحزاب
اليساريه والاحزاب ايضا بعض الاحزاب
اليمنيه ولكن الان الوعي العامه في شارع
السوداني بعد الثوره اصبح وعيا لا يرتبط
كثيرا
ضيقه الان
الشعوب وبما شاهدوا العالم من تطور ونقل
كبيره جدا في مجالات مختلفه اصبحت الشعوب
تنظر الى مصالحها في الاساس اكثر من اي
شيء اخر لذلك يجب ان نميز بين
مرايا غمار الناس وراي النخب السياسيه
المختلفه
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه تحدثت عن رغبتها
رغبه اسرائيل في المشاركه بالتنميه في
السودان كيف ستكون هذه التنميه باي مجالات
انا اعتقد انه السودان الان به مجال واسع
في في ناحيه الزراعه
وانت تعلمي ان هناك النيل
وهناك ارض خصبه وما الى ذلك بالامكان ان
يتم تبادل المصالح في هذا الاتجاه في
اتجاه الزراعه وايضا في اتجاه الصناعه
والتصنيع اسرائيل لها يعني خبره ولها
تجربه في هذا المجال بالامكان ان تكون
هناك مصالح مشتركه بين السودان واسرائيل
في الجانب الزراعي وبعض الجوانب الصناعيه
وخلافه
سيد عادل يعني هل يمكن توقيع اتفاق
التطبيع مع اسرائيل في هذه المرحله
الحساسه في السودان
والسلطه هي بمرحله انتقاليه يعني
اذا اعتبرنا انه الاتفاق سيتم توقيعه
عندما تكون هناك حكومه مدنيه ماذا ان رفض
المدنيون ماذا ان رفض الشعب ذلك هل يحق
لهذه الحكومه اسقاط الاتفاق
قانونيا ودستوريا
انا اعتقد انه ده متوقع ده هذا متوقع بلا
شك خصم انه القوه السياسيه كما اسلفت لك
لها براج ولها رؤى ايدولوجيه مصممه على
التفكير
الايديولوجي تجاه دوله اسرائيل ولكن ايضا
ذكرت بان الشعوب الشعب السوداني الان اصبح
يعني لا تهمه مصلحته
وليس لديه مشكله بهذا الاتفاق يعني كيف
لذلك انا قلت لك يجب ان قلت لك يجب ان
نميز بين الموقف العام موقف الشعب
السوداني وبين موقف النخب السياسيه
طبعا بالضروره المرحله القادمه
وبحسب الاتفاق الاطاري ستكون مرحله بين
المكونه العسكري وبين المكونه المدني او
الذي تمثله القوه السياسيه لذلك انا اعتقد
انه التسريع في عمل اختراق في هذا الملف
في هذه المرحله نعتقد انه مطلوب وايجابي
ومن الممكن ان يؤدي في المستقبل الى نتائج
ايجابيه ولكن في ظل الاجهزه
ستكون موجوده في المرحله القادمه
والمؤسسات انا اعتقد انه المساله سيكون
فيها بطي في الاجراءات لذلك الخطوه اللي
تمت اليوم انا اعتقد انه هي مقصوده
كاستباق للمرحله المتوقعه بعد تنفيذ بنود
الاتفاق الايطالي
جزيلا لك من الخرطوم الصحفي عادل سيد احمد
وتتابعون معنا ولكن بعد الفاصل
اوكرانيا تتاهب لاكبر هجوم منذ بدايه
الحرب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت تقارير ان اوكرانيا
تتاهب لهجوم روسي كبير محتمل في غضون ايام
يعتبره محللون اكبر هجوم منذ بدايه الحرب
هنا جرت احدى اهم معارك الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
وفي المكان ذاته روسيا تحتفل بذكرى هزيمه
الالمان وتستعرض قوتها العسكريه
العرض العسكري يوازيه حشد روسي شرقي
اوكرانيا تاهبا لشن اكبر هجوم منذ بدء
الحرب حيث تم حشد نحو 500 الف جندي لتنفيذ
هذا الهجوم وفق وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
الذي توقع ان يبدا الهجوم تزامنا مع
الذكرى الاولى للحرب المخاوف الاوكرانيه
من حمله جديده رافقها اقرار كييف بضغط
روسي يستهدف الشرق في ليمان وبخمود بخموت
المحاصره بشرق اوكرانيا يتركز القتال
حولها بعد اكثر من عشره شهور من المعارك
الداميه التي استنزفت الطرفين اما في
منطقه دومباس فتكثف روسيا حجم قواتها بشكل
كبير سعيا للسيطره عليها وتستعد موسكو
لفتح جبهه جديده حيث تسعى الى ان تتقدم
قواتها عبر الحدود الروسيه لاستعاده
الاراضي التي فلتت من قبضتها في سوم اوخر
كيف
حشد مئات الالاف من القوات واستهداف عشرات
الاماكن يوميا استراتيجيه القوات الروسيه
بينما تقديرات المخابرات الاوكرانيه تشير
الى ان روسيا نشرت ما يقرب من 300 وعشرين
الف جندي مؤخرا اوكرانيا التي تنتظر
الدبابات والعربات المدرعه وانظمه الاسلحه
الاخرى من الغرب تكافح للاحتفاظ بارضها
على امتداد 200 وخمسه وعشرين كيلومترا في
الشرق
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
قال الرئيس خلال كلمته بمناسبه الذكرى 80
لمعركه ستالينغراد ان الغرب يريد القتال
في اوكرانيا بايادي خلفاء هتلر عبر ارسال
دبابات لبوارد الالمانيه مهددا بالرد على
ارسال الدبابات لك
للاسف نرى ايديولوجيه النازيه عادت لتشكل
خطرا مباشرا على امن بلدنا ونحن مضطرون من
جديد ان نجابه عدوان الغرب الذين يهددوننا
بدبابات الالمانيه ويريدون الان ان
يحاربوا في اوكرانيا على ايدي خلفاء هتلر
تهديدات بوتنجات في وقت دعى فيه البرلمان
الاوروبي دول الاتحاد الى تبني الحزمه
العاشره من العقوبات ضد روسيا قريبا وحضر
الشركات الروسيه في السوق الاوروبيه وداع
البرلمان ايضا خلال جلسته اليوم الى
التخلي عن استيراد اليورانيوم من روسيا
بالاضافه للنفط والغزه
من جانبه دعا رئيس الاوكراني فردا مزيد من
الاجراءات العقابيه ضد روسيا من قبل
الاتحاد الاوروبي وكشف زيلينسكي انه ناقش
حزمه عقوبات جديده من الاتحاد الاوروبي
على موسكو مع رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ارسل مدنيين
ناقشنا عقوبات جديده ضد روسيا الحزمه
العاشره من عقوبه الاتحاد الاوروبي على
وجه الخصوص المهمه المشتركه للاتحاد
الاوروبي هي تقليل قدره روسيا على تجاوز
العقوبات وكلما تم تحقيق ذلك في وقت مبكر
اقتربنا من هزيمه العدوان الروسي لاحظنا
ان وتيره العقوبات قليلا بينما سارعت
روسيا بالتكيف علينا اصلاح ذلك اعتقد انه
بامكاننا القيام بالامر
ومن ابو ظبي ينضم الينا عبر زوم فيتالي
فديانيين الدبلوماسي الاوكراني اهلا بك
معنا ليلى سيد فيتالي يعني قمه اوكرانيه
في كييف ما المتوقع منها يعني بعد كل
الدعم العسكري الاوروبي المشروط ولا محدود
لاوكرانيا ما الذي تريده اوكرانيا بعد
مساء الخير يا كرام مساء الخير استوديو
تحدث اوكرانيا الى التحقيق نتائج ملموسه
في القمه القادمه بين اوكرانيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي غدا
اولا تستعيد اوكرانيا لاظهار نتائج تنفيذ
جميع التوصيات السبعه للمفوضيه الاوروبيه
خلال القمه اتحاد الاورو والاوروبي
واوكرانيا من بين تلك التوصيات اصلاح
المحكمه الدستوريه واصلاح النظام القضائي
ومكافحه الفساد ومكافحه التغسيل الاموال
واقرار قانون مكافحه
وفي كل هذه المجالات حققت اوكرانيا تقدم
الملموسه ونامل في الحصول على تقييم
ايجابي لمصاعنا من قبل الاتحاد الاوروبي
واقرار قرار حول بدء المفاوضات حول انضمام
واوكرانيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وطبعا
نريد التوصل الى الاتفاق بخصوص الحزمه
العاشره
للعقوبات المفروضه على روسيا لان روسيا
تواصل عدوانها على اوكرانيا
ومن المفروض تعزيز وتيره العقوبات وخاصه
الفرض العقوبات على صناعات الطائرات
المسيره الروسيه وكمان الصناعات الصواريخ
الروسيه المستخدمه لضربات الارهابيه على
اهداف المدنيه في اوكرانيا وقتل المدنيين
هذا من اهم الاحداث التي نريد توصل اليها
خلال هذه القمه سيد فيتالي يعني الموضوع
الاساس الذي
ذكرته سيكون انضمام اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي لماذا حتى الان لم يعني تحل كل
العراقيل لانضمامكم يعني الجميع مجمع على
انه اوكرانيا تدفع الثمن بدلا عن الغرب عن
الدول الغربيه كلها ما هي تلك العراقيل
امام ما دفعته اوكرانيا من ضحايا ومن خراب
ودمار
تدفع اوكرانيا
اعلى سعر لهذا العدوان وان اوكرانيا من
الدول التي تريد
احلال السلام يعني اكثر من اي دوله الاخرى
في العالم
وبخصوص انضمام اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي اليوم تمر اوكرانيا عبر لحظه
التاريخيه الفريده لما تبلغ نسبه
الاوكرانيين يؤيدون انضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي 86% يعني اكثر اكثر من 80% يعني
اغلبيه ساحقه
ما المشكله
واليوم لدينا الرغبه السياسيه مطلقه وعزم
حديدي لاجراء لاصلاحات المطلوبه لدى رئيس
دوله والحكومه والبرلمان جاهزيه الدامه
اليوم للعمل الفعال
لاجراء كل هذه الاصلاحات المطلوبه كما قلت
يعني اصلاحات النظام القضائي واصلاحات
واقرار الق المطلوبه ونتوقع القرار الصادر
عن المفوضيه الاوروبيه
حول تقدم النوبات على المفاوضات للانضمام
في اقرب وقت ممكن في ربيع ونحن يعني اتخاذ
هذا القرار خلال هذه القمه طيب هناك
تحذيرات من هجوم روسي بالرابع والعشرين من
فبراير هل من معلومات لديكم حوله باختصار
لو سمحت
نعم للاسم للاسف لم تتخلى روسيا عن هدفها
الرئيسي استراتيجي في احتلال والتدمير
اوكرانيا بشكل كامل كدوله ولذا واذا نحن
يجب ان نصوت كل شيء
للرفع الجاهزيه وقدرات الدفاعيه
الاوكرانيه في التصدي هذا العدوان وهذا
الهجوم المحتمل
وعقد هذه القيمه في هذا الوقت مهم جدا لان
نحن اليوم
نشوف كل هذا الدعم التام من قبل شركائنا
الاوروبيين في التصدي هذا العضوان ونحن
يجب ان نكون متحدين يعني بشكل يعني بشكل
جيد يعني في مواجهه هذا العدوان لان عندنا
اوكرانيا تسعى مع الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
التحقيق الهدف الواحد وهو تامين السلام
دائم ومستدام في اوروبا
وانضمام اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
ستعزز الامر في اوكرانيا وفي القاره
الاوروبيه كلها وفي العالم كمان شكرا
جزيلا لك
الدبلوماسي الاوكراني حدثنا من ابو ظبي
[موسيقى]
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال مسؤول
العلاقات العامه في الحزب الديمقراطي
الكردستاني الايراني المعارض محمد نظيف
قادري ان النظام الايراني يتعامل مع
المتظاهرين ورجال الدين والاقليات باقصى
الاساليب والسياسه الضغط والتعذيب
والاعتقال
نحن نشوف يعني حالات
واجهت النظام الايراني مع متظاهرين يعني
هما يقومون باسوا حاله تعامل مع متظاهرين
بنات
شباب طلاب الجامعات حتى الشخصيات الدينيه
تشوف حسب في زاهدان في كردستان في منطقه
الاعواس
وباقي مناطق الايران مواطنين يواجهون
بسياسه
اعتقال والتعذيب نشيتين المجتمع المدني
محمد نظيف قادر اضاف ان الصراعات موجوده
بين الحرس الثوري الايراني والبرلمان
والجيش وبيت المرشد الايراني بما في ذلك
خلافات داخل مؤسسه الحرس الثوري الايراني
في
داخل النظام الايراني موشي جديد بس حاليا
يواصل الى اعلى حاله
صراع بين الحرس الثوري مع مجلس
[موسيقى]
شورايم اللي مجلس
البرلمان الايراني
صراع بين الحرس الثوري مع الجيش صراع بين
الحرس الثوري مع بيت
ايضا في داخل الحرس الثوري
وهذا واسع لكل ناس ووازع للكل الجهات
السياسيه وامنيه
في الذكرى السنويه الاولى لفقدان ابنها
ريان العائله المغربيه تحتفل بمولود ذكر
التفاصيل بعد
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ابقت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على قرارها بهدم قريه الخان
الاحمر شرق القدس لكن مع تاجيل الهدم حتى
الصيف وتبقى امال السكان معلقه على امل
ضغط دولي يجنب السكان تهجير القصري
لا غرابه ان تجري هذه الطفله حافيه في هذا
الجو البارد والماطر انه دفء المكان الذي
ولدت فيه رغم انها باتت تدرك وفي هذا
العمر الصغير انه قد يفقد في اي لحظه هذا
ما قاله لنا سكان القريه البدويه الخان
الاحمر ان اطفالهم يوجهون لهم اسئله
مصيريه لا يملكون لها اجابه احنا عايزين
لنفهم اطفالنا فلا صغار يعجزوك في الاسئله
احنا عايزين نفهمهم كل مده دخول سياره ما
يشوفوا يعني ما انت متريح لا في الليل ولا
في النهار للمره التاسعه تضطر الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لتاجيل تنفيذ امر هدم واخلاء
الخان الاحمر الذي اقرته المحكمه
الاسرائيليه
ورغم ان جمعيات استيطانيه وضعت حكومه
نتنياهو في الزاويه قضائيا لتنفيذ الاخلاء
الا ان الضغوط الامريكيه كانت اقوى هذه
المره فهذا التجمع البدوي المبني من بي
صفيح اصبح بقاؤه يعني بقاء خيار حل
الدولتين هنا ممر هنا مركز السلام ليس
لانه بيت موجود هنا لانه اذا تم اقتلاع
هذه القريه سيتم هناك بناء المستوطنين قطع
الدفع الغربيه شمال وجنوب الفريق الامريكي
السياسي والامني الموجود في المنطقه نجح
في اول خطوه نحو التهدئه لكن المهمه تبدو
معقده وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي لم يستجب
للضغوط وقررك قطاع نحو 30 مليون دولار من
اموال الفلسطينيين فيما يواصل بنجبير
اجراءاته العقابيه بحق الاسرى الفلسطينيين
في السجون ما يهدد بانفجار ميداني في اي
لحظه
تتوقفهم الاطماع الاستيطانيه وتهديدات
بنجافير من جهه والضغوط الامريكيه
والمساعي الاوروبيه من الجهه الاخرى ورغم
كل هذا الواقع الصعب والمستقبل المجهول
ينجح هؤلاء البدو حتى هذه اللحظه في
البقاء على ارضهم من قريه الخان الاحمر
عبد الحفيظ العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
في جديد التطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي تشير
التقديرات الى ان تشاد جي بي تي اتابع
لابن اي قد سجل مئه مليون مستخدم نشط
شهريا في يناير الماضي بعد شهرين فقط من
اطلاقه الامر الذي يجعله الموقع الاسرع
نموا في التاريخ وفقا لتقرير اجراه بان
كيو بي اس وذكرت تقرير ان 13 مليون زائر
في المتوسط استخدمت تشاد جي بي تي يوميا
في يناير اي اكثر من ضعف مستويات ديسمبر
الماضي واعلنت الشركه عن اشتراك شهري قدره
20 دولارا مبدئيا للمستخدمين في الولايات
المتحده فقط مشيره الى انها ستوفر خدمه
اكثر استقرارا واسرع بالاضافه الى فرصه
تجربه ميزات جديده يذكر ان تشاد جي بي تي
للدردشه يجيب على اسئله وطلبات المستخدمين
باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي وقادر على حل
مسائل رياضيه معقده وكتابه رموز ايضا
ايضا ابتكرت شركه اوبن اي صاحبه موقع تشاد
جي بي تي اداه برمجيه جديده لتحديد وكشف
النص الذي تم انشاؤه بواسطه الذكاء
الاصطناعي وتمييزه من النصوص المكتوبه
بواسطه الانسان واشارت الى ان الاداه
الجديده تعمل على معالجه قضايا مثل
المعلومات الخاطئه والخداع الاكاديمي وسط
التزايد الانتقادات لتطبيق الشركه
بانه يساعد التلاميذ على الغش واشارت
الشركه الى ان الاداه الجديده غير موثوقه
في النصوص التي تقل عن الف حرف وفي النصوص
المكتوبه من قبل الذكاء الذكاء الاصطناعي
التي تم تحريرها لاحقا من قبل الانسان
[موسيقى]
مذكراتها الامير هاري تواصل اثاره الجدل
من خلال ما تكشف عنه من خبايا من بينها
اسرار تخص الامير ويليام وهو الابن الاكبر
للملك تشارلز والاول في ترتيب ولايه العرش
البريطاني وهو الملك في المستقبل فنقلا عن
ما جاء في كتاب الامير فان الملك
البريطاني المستقبل خالف قواعد وبروتوكول
الاسره الملكيه فما هي هذه القواعد التي
خلفها الامير وليمون يقول الامير هاري في
مذكراته انا اخاه ان اخاه الامير ويليام
اطلق لحيته في العام 2008 خلال رحله
استغرقت عشره ايام الى بربادوس وتقول
المذكرات ان ويليام ربما يكون قد اطلق
لحيته لاخفاء هويته اثناء الرحله علما ان
القصر لا يمانع اطلاق الملكيين للحيه لكن
اثناء الخدمه في القوات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
الى فيديو اليوم وهو من المغرب يوم السادس
من فبراير 2023 يصادف الذكرى السنويه
الاولى لوفاه الطفل المغربي الصغير ريانا
الذي سقط في بئر بمدينه شفشاون شمال
البلاد في حادثه لقيت تفاعلا واسعا عربيا
وعالميا الا انه رغم اقتراب هذه الذكرى
الاليمه ولد الفرح وسط عائله ريان حيث
رزقت بمولود ذكر بعد حادث شد انظار وقلوب
العالم في فبراير الماضي
والان ننتقل مع انتهاء حلقتنا ومواضيعنا
الى زميل صهيب شراير واخبار الساعه مساء
الخير يا صهيب مساء الخير راويه بالفعل
قصه ريان ما تزال تصنع الحدث يعني الله
عوض الوالدين بولد ذكر لا اعتقد لا اعرف
اسم الاسم الذي اطلقاه على المولود ولكن
انت مع ان يسمى ريان ام لا هلا مش غلط
ولكن يعني خلي يكون في هيك فل يعني يكون
عنده حظ ربما احلى من حظ ريان اللي كان
عمره قصير ولكن كلنا نتفاعل يعني هذا
الخبر جميل جدا لانه تاخرنا الى ايام
الترقيه الصعبه طبعا المحزنه لقصه ريان
شكرا لك راوي بطول العمر يا رب